I see this guy here do i I see this guy
back here can we can we break can we
bring them in to this interview
can we bring you in oh this is what a
monumental moment is this a date night
out guys hi this is like a really weird
coincidence that we happen to be like
all right this thing I just wanna say I
think Chloe Bennett's dope and it's it's
I'm glad that she's here at the same
time as me promoting Logan Paul versus
say yeah you weekend
Chloe's explosion actress and you know
agents marvelous we have a movie coming
out next year called valley girl and
then all the speculation started on it I
don't know about that oh hello the news
I know it I know it's up so I want to
know the straight answer like fans want
to know I want to know come on
which is such a weird get Chloe Chloe
what's the straight answer I don't have
a straight answer what the straight
answer is that like straight up Chloe
Bennet it's dull yeah well you know did
you pre come up with that answer I've
been saying it for about six months now
it's good lots of certain thing is Logan
throwing glasses that he actually
doesn't need for the for actual reason
or not does not prescription glass
there's just no reason for them Asylum
Hollywood aesthetics seems like you guys
have good chemistry can you can you
respond to that comment we do we do we
do a really good catch with you that's
why the movies gonna be so good that
comes out I'm really excited to see how
we are on a screen in a movie who's
gonna be my big day Chloe
you